back at bug bunker HQ what the heck is
this Valerie Rachel and Jessie are
testing an adhesive myth for the ages is
it possible to build a giant-sized glue
trap and catch a human this one is
definitely sticky and after testing and
then eliminating a bunch of store-bought
options because their mechanical
properties just weren't up to the scale
of a human being
the Mythbusters went for some min scale
test oh definitely sticky and settled
upon a glue they think is perfect and
just might succeed at this and that is a
whopping 60 gallons of off-the-shelf
rodent glue a proprietary formula that
combines linseed oil and polyurethane
derivatives for viscosity and adhesive
power my favorite part is that they
ended up with a glue actually meant for
catching animals in this case rodents
but oh my gosh I can't even tell you how
sticky this stuff is it is really gross
and I feel like it just might work I was
looking a different finger
[Music]
you understand if we get stuck in this
we're stuck for good so now it's time
for the full-scale test ladies and
gentlemen welcome to the Buster Motel
we're Mythbusters go win and he might
just not make it out suitably attired
welcome to the gun show
Valerie volunteers to make the first run
good luck thank you
I'm about to run through 450 pounds of
glue all right cue the lights I've had
nightmares about this but it's time to
face them and with cautionary confidence
valerie takes the plunge one shoe down
two hands down Kenny Sinha and Valerie's
out of the rest oh my god round one is
conclusive oh there we go
awesome the glue knock Valerie socks off
oh [ __ ]
that caught me that's what we caught me
totally caught you totally Wow
round two Rachel's up I have a technique
that twinkle toes
I think it'll work better because the
surface area is less and I'll be able to
pull it out quicker so I think it'll
work mark my words
alright a human trial of our bug trap
[Music]
your arms down oh yeah okay I thought
that twinkle toes tactic would work
apparently not because I'm stuffed like
a bug with the score of glue to
Mythbusters zip it's all down to Jesse
Jesse's got no shot I'm going to try and
jump onto the platform without face
planning into a bunch of glue it sounds
like a perfect plan
this is human bug trap in three two one
are you all right I don't know
well Jesse took a huge leap at the
beginning to hopefully get farther than
Valerie made it across our bug trap and
he did before just before face planting
into the stuff and he was genuinely
caught
I'm starting to think I should get a
pair of scissors and just cut you out of
this suit from the I think that would be
great right okay so when he emerged from
the suit he went a pool it kind of sound
like a fart
and an explosion in one just like pull
right in your face there's no contest I
stuck out and definitely been stuck
the Mythbusters are three down all out
dad as they say that's all folks
except to call the myth I have to say I
am impressed this is a lot weirder and a
lot funnier than I thought it was going
to be but question is how do we call it
is it possible to supersize a bug trap
and catch a person if you came across
the system normal street clothes crying
to your mommy
yeah you guys all did tank on the first
attempt so totally confirmed
I agree confirmed confirmed confirmed
all right let's clean this mess up
somehow
[Music]
you